welcome back to CBS this morning you're
looking at the SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket at
the Kennedy Space Center in Florida and
it is quite a sight weather permitting
it is scheduled will blast off at 433
Eastern Time this afternoon
carrying two NASA astronauts to the
International Space Station it will be
the first time a private company
launches humans into orbit as part of
our launch America coverage mark
strassman talked to SpaceX founder Elon
Musk it's his only broadcast network
interview before today's launch I'm the
chief engineer the thanks I just like to
say if it goes right it's credit to the
SpaceX NASA team goes wrong it's my
fault you believe that yeah absolutely
we met Elon Musk and NASA Administrator
Jim bridenstine inside Kennedy Space
Center's launch control center
this is SpaceX is firing room where must
we'll watch today's scheduled liftoff
his Falcon 9 rocket stood on launch pad
39a the same pad that sent Apollo 11 to
the moon st. crevel honored to be on
this launch pad for sure immensely
grateful this is 39a is like Times
Square it's not just opening a play on
Broadway so opening play it on Pine
Square okay it's like it's the best pad
in the world what does this moment mean
to you well this is the culmination of a
dream this is a dream come true in fact
it feels surreal if you'd asked me when
starting SpaceX if this would happen I'd
be like one percent point one percent
chance since SpaceX launched 18 years
ago musk has revolutionized rocketry and
the business model of space travel his
Falcon 9 rocket is reusable a milestone
breakthrough because it slashes
the dominant cost of launching
bridenstine says that sort of corporate
innovation is key to NASA's future - and
now for the first time the government is
saying look we want to be a customer for
sure but we want to be one customer of
many and we want to have numerous
providers that are competing on cost and
innovation this is the beginning of a
commercial marketplace in space SpaceX
has had 19 successful launches of cargo
to the
International Space Station but with
this launch for the first time SpaceX
will carry people NASA astronauts Bob
Behnken and Doug Hurley by far it's the
company's most pivotal test is there one
thing that keeps you up at night about
this launch not one thing no there's a
lot of things there's a million things
have to go right yes thousands of things
that can go wrong and only one thing it
could all right anything anyone can
think of to improve the poverty success
and make sure Bob and Doug are safely
taken to the space station that is the
absolute priority in fact I've told
SpaceX team it is not simply the top
priority it is the only priority how
does that responsibilities weigh on you
weighs very heavily it's really all I
can think about right now I really kind
of have to kind of mentally block it
because otherwise it would be
emotionally impossible to deal with it's
not significant yes you know I was
asking them just just a few hours ago
it's like you guys feel good about this
is you know it was anything you wanted
to do and and they're cool cool as a
cucumber I mean they're just like nerves
of steel it's astonishing I mean they
were ready to go I sent him a text
yesterday and I I said if there's
anything you want me to do stop it in a
heartbeat yes and both of them said
we're go for launch both of us so the
astronauts are cooler than YouTube all
right I think so probably one of Bryden
Stein's goals get Americans excited
about space again a successful launch
would do that NASA is also working with
actor Tom Cruise to film a space movie
wait for it aboard the space station
what is the deal with astronaut Tom
Cruise actually I think that remains to
be seen we're supportive and I think I
think NASA support of anything that
captures the imagination of the public
if they want to go to the International
Space Station and make a movie and
inspire a generation of that's exactly
what we're looking at school something
that I don't often admit but I became a
Navy pilot because I watched the movie
Top Gun when I was in sixth grade and it
changed my life the question is is Tom
Cruise making a movie about going to the
International
is he going to inspire the next Elan
musk that's the question and if he can
do that then we win but for SpaceX to
fly Tom Cruise or anyone else down the
road first they have to nail this launch
and this mission it started raining here
just a few minutes ago but launch
conditions are actually 60% favorable in
the weather department there's growing
concern though about weather out in the
Atlantic where the capsule would have to
ditch if the launch run into a
significant problem and Anthony if today
is a no-go for weather or any other
reason the next launch window would be
Saturday afternoon okay mark I'm I've
saw the raindrops on your jacket and I
was thinking oh I hope this holds up it
doesn't hold up the hope that moves away
but listen if they're if they're trying
to excite us about the space program
they're doing a really good job I just I
remember going out almost 18 years ago
when they first start when they first
started SpaceX and I never imagined this
mark
Gale I know listen I'm with you Anthony
when I saw the raindrops on Marc's
jacket I want rot row but I'm so
ignorant it's so excited and it just
shows you that your imagination is
limitless I can't wait to see what
happens this afternoon or Saturday we
have to wait a couple of days that is
okay Tony yeah guys count me excited as
well I don't need Tom Cruise to go up
there and make a movie to get me
inspired about space like I think of the
mess that we've made here from time to
time here on earth and and maybe we can
do better up there once we get there and
if the long months can help us more
power to them though I'm nervous with
them but best of luck and I hope that
rain moves off